ALI AFSHAR: Hello, everyone.
Welcome to Google
Developers Live.
Today we're going to be talking
about searching for
files using the Google
Drive API.
Now, Google, obviously
we do search.
Hopefully we do it well.
That's no exception
with Google Drive.
So I'm just going to open my
Google Drive now and show you
what it looks like
for the user.
And then we'll do that for a
couple of minutes, and then
we'll go on to how it is
for the developer.
So I've pre-created a couple
of files here--
Fruits and vegetables and
fruitsandvegetables.pdf.
Let's have a look
at one of them.
So the first one is just a
list of some fruits and
vegetables.
I'm want you to notice
a couple of things.
The first one is the title.
Is fruits and vegetables.
And secondly, there's a list--
banana, apple, orange, pair,
lemon, mango, cucumber.
Now, what I did earlier is I
exported this file as a PDF,
except it's not the
whole file.
I created just five fruits
in there first and
then exported that.
So this is actually a PDF also
in Google Drive, and this has
only got banana, apple, orange,
pair, lemon, and it's
got a similar kind
of title, OK?
So if I go to Google Drive, and
if I search for banana, I
find lots of stuff.
Actually, I like bananas.
But one of them is this--
fruitsandvegetables.pdf.
We see we opened that.
So interesting to see, Google
Drive has scanned that PDF,
and it knows the content, so
that when you type one of the
textual content in this binary
file, it looks it up for you,
and it finds it.
So that's great, and it found
our other one as well.
Here it is--
fruitsandvegetables.
OK, now if I just search for one
of the terms that's only
in the Google Doc, not in the
PDF, so that's going to be
cucumber here, we see we
only get the one file.
Obviously, that's
how it works.
So that's the general
flow for the user.
So Google Drive API aims to be
able to do anything the user
can do in Google Drive and
be able to do it via a
programmatic interface,
the Google Drive API.
So let's switch immediately to
our Python shell, and let's
have a try on that.
So this is bPython.
I've got the Python client
library installed, and I've
got an authorized HTTP instance
ready to be imported.
That's just saving us a couple
of minutes of time.
So the first thing we're going
to do is import the HTTP
instance called authorization.
That's in my library called Auth
that I can share with you
if anyone's interested.
Secondly, I want to create
a Drive instance.
This is standard for you all.
Let's import from
apiclient.discovery.
Import Build and Drive,
which is going
to our Drive service--
Drive equals build, then the
name of the API, and the
version of the API.
This goes off to the discovery
service, finds the schema for
this API, and builds a service
dynamically in Python
that can use that.
And let's not forget to use our
authorized HTTP instance
so we don't need to parse that
ever time on every call.
So let's create that,
and let's make
sure we've got something.
So Drive, there it is.
Now, when you want to search
files in the Google Drive API,
you can apply a query
to any list
operation involving files.
So that's really files.list,
or children.list, you can
apply these queries.
We're just going to use
files.list for now, and we're
going to create some
queries to see.
So the first one I'd like
to do is the basic query
that we just did.
So we're going to search for
banana, or apple, or something
like this, so drive.files.list.
So we could just run that for
now, and that would just list
all of them.
But by passing the queue
parameter is a query created
by whatever parameters
you want.
Let's just have a quick look
at these parameters in our
documentation.
So these are the fields
available--
Title, Full Text, MIME Type,
Modified Date, Last Viewed By
Me Date, Trash, Start,
Hidden, Parent.
So all of these you can see
them, and that's in our
documentation--
developers.google.com/drive--
and under the tag of
search parameters.
That's where you
can find that.
So we have these parameters.
We also have some operators,
depending on how you want to
apply it-- "in" for collections,
"contains" for
strings within others strings.
"Equals," obviously, is
equality, "less than" and
"greater than" for dates.
And you can combine these terms
with "and" and you can
negate these terms with "not."
So that's pretty much whatever
you want to do.
So back to the shell.
So we want to say, OK,
we want fruit in
the title, for example.
I'm going to use double quotes
here, because the query
language uses single quotes.
So fruit, and the field
title contains fruit.
How about that?
So we'll do that, and we'll
execute it, and we
see loads of stuff.
OK, so this just shows us that
we've found a search.
It's not an empty result.
So what I'm going to do now is
I'm going to write a quick
function to be able to run these
queries and return us
more useful information
that fits on a page.
So we're going to call it
"execute query," and it's
going to take a query that we'll
call "q." That will be a
string that's parsed in.
And what's it going to do?
Well, let's have a look.
Items equals drive.files.list.
q equals q.execute.
Let's graph the items deck.
There will be a list of items
that have been returned.
And then let's just print
the length of that.
We don't really want to see all
the individual items, so
print length.
Results found.
And a full stop to be good.
And let's just test that out.
So execute query, and let's
do the same one.
So fruit, title contains
fruit.
Title contains fruit.
Here's where it doesn't work.
There we go, two
results found.
So those are our two files,
and that's great.
So let's play about with that.
So we have title.
Title here is the field that
we're going to be looking for.
So if you want to search within
the full text, you just
say full text equals fruit.
And full text obviously includes
the title and the
body of the file itself.
So we found our two results.
Now, let's do the query for a
type of fruit that we know is
in the body.
So let's try banana, and we know
there are more results.
There were eight.
Remember, we found the those
eight results earlier.
And let's do a mango that
is only in the doc,
and not in the PDF.
And there you go.
It's only in one result found.
So what I really want to
show you here is that
it's treating PDFs--
and it does the same for images
that have text in them.
It's treating them as if they're
plain text files or
text files that can
be indexed.
Massively useful.
Essentially doing OCR on your
stuff and being able to return
the results with the queries
that you provide.
So that's that one.
And there are other
query parameters.
So we're going to do a few, and
we're going to show you a
few more operators.
So MIME type, that's
a pretty cool one.
So you can query by MIME type.
I just want mime type equals--
and let's think of an easy one
to type-- application PDF.
This is all the PDFs
in my Google Drive.
That's 22 results.
It's pretty great.
Another thing we can
do is we can look
at the parent hierarchy.
So I can say I want files
that are only
within a certain directory.
So let's do another
query here.
Let's say I want files that
are in the root directory.
Now, root is a special alias for
the base directory in your
Google Drive.
And so this means files that
are in that are not in any
other folders.
So root in parents, and
we've got six results.
So if we go back to Google
Drive, we can see that there
are others there.
So it's looking at these four
and a couple of others that
I've hidden away.
So that's that.
So that's the parents.
And again, we can look at in
children, which looks at which
files are children
of the folder.
So we have that case covered.
Combining these, that's
pretty cool.
You can combine these as well.
So you can say root in parents
and full text contains mango.
That should return one result,
and it has done that.
So this is looking for files
that are in the root
directory, and the full
text contains mango.
And you can just
combine these.
So let's see, and not full
text contains mango.
So this wants stuff in the
directory that is not
containing the word mango.
And we see the six
files there.
So using this, you can combine
these search queries.
We also have a few little tweaks
here and there that
we've added to make the
stuff more useful.
One thing we just launched
yesterday, actually, is a
query that people have been
asking for on Stack Overflow,
and personally I
think something
that's very, very useful.
It's called Shared with Me.
So that's the complete query
is you just execute "shared
with me."
And that returns files in the
Google Drive that have been
shared with me.
If you wanted to do that query
otherwise, you'd have to say,
well, I'm not the owner of the
file, but I am in the readers,
or I am in the writers,
something like that.
You'd have to create that query,
and it's not exactly
perfect, and people have
been having trouble.
So we've just launched this--
Shared with Me--
and that returns those
28 results.
Really, really useful if you
want to separate what your
files are and what someone
else's files are, which leads
me to searching for permissions
on files.
So you can say I want files
where I am a writer.
So you would say me, and that
is another alias for my
username, but I can just
aafshar@gmail.com in writers.
So these are files that I
can write to, I have the
permission to write to.
And then we get 99 results.
Actually, it's bigger
than that.
99 is the page size.
So if you wanted the next set
of pages, you'd do that.
And these files are
all my images.
I have thousands of images in
my Google Drive photographs.
So this is just looking
at them.
Again, if I do readers, we
should again get 99 results.
That's all the files
I can read.
And the last one is owners.
OK And that's going to take a
bigger query, and it's taking
a bit of time.
100 results found.
So let's combine this query
with the "shared with me"
query to see what happens.
So this is files which are
shared with me, and
I'm an owner of.
It's quite an interesting
case.
It means someone has shared
me the file and made me
the owner of it.
Zero results.
It's not going to happen very
often that someone shares you
a file and makes you an owner.
It's more likely they'll share
the file, allow you to write
or comment on it, and will
read it, but maintain
ownership in it for
themselves.
So that's searching.
As I say, we've got
documentation here.
We have a number of examples
that I encourage you to try.
Title equals hello, MIME
type we showed you.
Title contains, negation,
we showed you.
Using the full text, which is
the body and the description,
and the title.
We showed you how to search
by permission, as in using
in-writers, in-readers.
We showed you how to test for
the parent hierarchy, as in
using the in-parents query.
We showed you how to combine
queries together using the
"and" operator, and we showed
you how to negate queries with
the "not" operator.
I see at the end we've got just
one more query, which is
the date style queries.
And that's where you can use
greater than, less than,
greater than or equal to to
specify what the relationship
is with the date.
So greater than a date
means after a date.
It kind of makes sense.
So, hang on.
Let's just copy paste that
query and run it.
Execute query.
Oops.
So this is going to look for
files with a modified date
after the fourth and the
sixth of this year.
And that's going to be a lot--
100 results found.
Let's find files that are
modified before then.
And that might be
zero, actually.
I think I cleaned out
my Google Drive.
Oh, no.
That's more as well.
So I do have some old files
and some new files.
Let's put an earlier
date in here, so we
can kind of get this.
I don't know, 2007.
There you go.
So no files in my Drive were
modified before then.
As usual, we're keen to get you
up and running on this.
If you find something you want
to search for but you can't do
immediately, if you find that
any particular queries are
slow, these are things we really
need to know about.
So please let us know.
Let us know on Stack Overflow.
I'm always available.
You can contact me on Google+
or on Gmail, things we
absolutely, absolutely,
need to know about
If you find anything good, or
you want something expanded,
also let us know.
So that's searching in
the Google Drive API.
Thank you very much, and
we look forward to
hearing from you.
[MUSIC PLAYING]